we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
very specific question about IQ and
donald trump hi David I'm a huge fan of
your show I watched you almost every day
I'm 24
I work in staffing and recruiting in
Houston right I'm look Y if you had to
guess what would you say from overall IQ
because if I had to guess I would say
it's at about ninety which maybe for the
average person it's not super low but of
course this president that is entirely
too low and you want to know something I
just don't feel he has the the IQ to do
the job so what are your thoughts what
would you think has overall i cuted
listen I don't really want to speculate
on Trump's IQ because the entire IQ
thing has been weaponized as as many of
you know with race IQ stuff with
overblowing the importance of IQ and the
connection of IQ to different measures
of success like what I can tell you is
Donald Trump clearly doesn't have the
temperament nor the knowledge nor the
attention span nor the personality to be
a good president he doesn't strike me as
a good person he doesn't seem able to
actually feel empathy he does not seem
to be able to engage in the sort of deep
learning and reading that is required
that President Obama was able to to
engage in to be a good president and
that's where I would focus my energy I
have no idea what Trump's IQ is there
are lots of people with a high IQ that
are bad people and therefore you still
don't want them as president so I I
understand what you're saying I think
that I would approach it sort of a
different way which is Trump has failed
us as president regardless of his IQ he
could have a 160 IQ who knows I don't
care he's a bad president and that's why
he needs to be removed in November okay
next there
they April 9th we are going to try to
have a coordinated membership explosion
all right there's going to be an email
going out to everybody on our mailing
list at 2 p.m. Eastern 11:00 a.m.
Pacific on Thursday April 9th with a
huge membership discount the biggest
discount of the year why are we doing
this on April 9th well couple things are
going on number one a lot of people are
canceling memberships because of
coronavirus and we don't want to reduce
ours we don't want to do layoffs we want
to just be able to keep things going and
so we want to kind of try to recover
some of those lost memberships we've
also had some advertisers that have had
to stop or cancel campaigns with us
because they aren't selling product so
they're not going to do advertising
right now and lastly April is the
anniversary of ad pocalypse 2017 so a
lot of the people who signed up in 2017
no doubt are going to have credit cards
that have expired and membership
payments that are going to fail so April
could be very ugly which is why on
Thursday April 9th at 2:00 p.m. Eastern
an email will go out with a huge
membership special I invite you to
participate sign up for our mailing list
you do it at david pakman.com top right
of the website you put in your email
address that's it ok don't email me
about this sign up at david pakman.com
and you'll be notified about this
special on Thursday April 9th join me on
the bonus show today we have updates
from the Pat producer Pat Ford Fiasco
involving a fire firefighters water a
collapsed ceiling it's a nutty story I
will give you the updates on today's
bonus show and we have much more to
discuss as well